[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP l'émission on
parle cuisine alimentation agriculture
écologie et même politique et cette
semaine nous recevons François Xavier de
maison bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et avec moi
pour présenter cette émission
Jean-Pierre Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre
bonjourit alors vous êtes humoriste et
acteur vous avez été révélé au grand
public en 2008 au cinéma avec le biopic
Coluche l'histoire d'un mec qui vous
vaut une nomination au César en 2009
dans la catégorie meilleur acteur depuis
on vous a vu dans le petit Nicolas o
vous interprétez bouillon c'est Monsieur
Dubon le pion de l'école vous avez été
remarqué aussi dans la comédie
dramatique comme des frères d'Hugo Gelin
votre carrière est bien alors que vous
ne la commencez que tardivement un peu
avant 30 ans où vous revenez à vos
premières amours le théâtre après un
détour perdu par la finance à New York
assez de faire du fric à vous la vie
d'artiste et de vigneron vous possédez
le domaine mirmanda qui se trouve en
Catalogne française un indice
Jean-Pierre pour le menu du jour oui
menu aux saveur du Sud avec une fidoa
catalane et en dessert un fiadon Corse
dans le dessous des plats des vignes
chez les Chtis avec le réchauffement les
haut de France cultiv désormais du
raisin dégustation dans cette émission
dans les pieds dans le plat attention au
préjugés la cuisine améicon n'est pas
seulement de la malbouffe vous allez le
voir elle peut nous régaler reportage à
suivre allez on passe à table tout de
suite cuisine et
[Musique]
confidence François Xavier de maison
pour parler de votre assiette histoire
de rendre hommage à coleluche que vous
avez incarné à l'écran j'avais envie de
raconter l'histoire d'un mec à table et
non pas sur le pont de l'Alma mais un
mec normal blanc un mec qui é au resto
et qui regarde dans son assiette pas con
le mec hein au bout d'une demi-heure il
y a un autre mec qui arrive et il voit
un mec qui est là et qui regarde dans
l'assiette et dis donc qu'est-ce que
vous faites à regarder dans l'assiette
l'autre lui dit bah je suis emmerdé
parce que j'ai laissé tomber mes
lunettes dans ma PAA alors l'autre lui
dit mais c'est pas une PAA c'est une
fillea alors l'autre lui dit ah bah vous
savez moi sans mes lunettes elle
rigolote
non
dans la version originale vous le savez
mieux que moi le mec est sur le pont de
l'ALEM et il confond la Loire et la
scène mais au-delà de cette pasimitation
de Coluche juste pour atterrir sur la
fidoa j'ai une question qu'est-ce qui
vous fait la préféré cette fidoa à la
PAA qui lui ressemble fichrement une
pointe de snobisme ou votre amour
aveugle pour la Catalogne exactement
c'est mon amour aveugle pour la
Catalogne
aveugle l'amour l'amour rent aveugle
puisque c'est une femme qui m'a conduit
en Catalogne ah je suis tombé amoureux
d'une catalane qui est très attachée à
sa terre et donc voilà c'était pas
négociable il a fallu que qu'on emménage
en Catalogne une partie enfin on a
acheté une maison avec des animaux et
voilà elle est très proche de sa terre
très proche de sa grand-mère de de toute
sa famille de sa mère qui habite à peu
près à 50 secondes de la maison donc on
est on est vraiment en clan et c'est
voilà c'est un village qui s'appelle
tuir que j'adore et c'est une des
spécialités ils sont très marqués par
l'Espagne ils sont à quelques quelques
minutes de l'Espagne et surtout la
famille de ma femme c'est une famille
qui a fait la Retirada c'est c'est ces
familles d'espagnol connaiss la
remontada mais la r ce sont les les ce
sont les républicains qui ont fu le
franquisme d'accord et qui sont venus
voilà qu'on passéit la frontière pour
fuir le Franquis et voilà et qui ont
travaillé dur et qui voilà ont ramené
quand même dans leur dans leur bagage
quelques recettes espagnoles donc on est
très marqué par la proximité de
l'Espagne et par cette culture espagnole
donc la fidoa est est un plat espagnol
qui se mange beaucoup en Catalogne oui
mais alors en fait la PA là c'est c'est
quand même plutôt c'est avec du riz là
on se retrouve c'est des pâtes
exactement ce sont des pâtes et je
trouve ça absolument délicieux on va la
goûter d'ailleurs on va la goûter allez
allonsy crois que c'est votre première
FID non prre envie de savoir ce que ça
ça se fait qu'estce que vous en
pensez est bonne elle est merveilleuse
et après je pourrais vous en parler un
peu est-ce qu'elle est comme comme
là-bas est-ce que- qu'elle a vraiment la
même saveur parf elle est absolument
parfaite alors les Catalans rajoutent de
la Yoli oui ah oui vra avec un peu d'ail
un petit peu beaucoup oui c'est ça pour
relever un peu le en fait c'est une
sauce sauce blanche qui mettent
carrément sur le plat et on mange et on
tartine ils en mange beaucoup de la Yoli
oui c'est vrai oui que vous en mangez le
lundi vous sentez la Yolie jusqu'au
jeudi soir quoi elle est meilleure que
celle que vous prépare votre femme
cherre là on va avoir des ennuis
Jeanpierre on va avoir des ennuis Joker
est-ce que c'est une est-ce que c'est
une insulte si on dit que c'est une une
PAA avec des pâtes non non c'est ça non
c'est vrai c'est pas ah non c'est pas
une insulte du tout non non pas du tout
d'accord et c'est du vermicel ou c'est
voilà alors je vais vous raconter tout
ça Brigit exactement trois choses à
savoir alors on parle de Fido à la
Catalane mais la légende Brigitte dit
que ce sont des pêcheurs de Gandia qui
était un petit port de pêche entre
Valence et Alicante qui aurait inventé
cette recette en 1915 Brigitte ils sont
partis en haute mer ils ont voulu faire
une PA là et mince il y a plus de riz
alors le cuisinier il a remplacé le riz
par ces petits fidéos là j'en ai amené
voyez ces petites vermissell
voilà il a remplacé ça par pares petits
vermicell de retour sur terre bien la
recette fut un vrai succès les
restaurateurs l'ont adopté et au fil du
temps c'est devenu un plat comme vous
l'avez dit complètement ibérique cousin
d'ELA la FDO va même s'exporter à
l'étranger et à Paris on peut la trouver
celle-ci vient du restaurant catalan le
Deric catalan l'authentique fidiawa est
un peu catalane je sais pas bien
pourquoi vous nous l'exliquer composé de
fruits de mer des gambases des moules
des sèches et puis on peut aussi servir
une fidewa noire avec de l'encre de
sèche j'adore celle-ci moi aussi moi
aussi j'adore l'encre de sèche de toute
façon effectivement benah c'est une
belle histoire com quoi les plus grand
les plus grands plat finalement c'est le
fruit d'une des circonstances on dit
souvent en au théâtre que l'art V
contraintte et MEUR de liberté la
cuisine aussi apparemment et c'est vrai
que la tarte tatin c'est une tarte ratée
renversé le poulet maringo c'est à un
moment donné il doit faire avec sur le
champ de bataille le napoléonou donc
c'est c'est vrai que c'est rigolo de
voir que ces grands plats naissent
souvent de des circonstances et des
contraintes qui sont et la Fido on la
trouve partout en Espagne maintenant ou
c'est oui oui je crois je
crois je crois en tout cas dans tout bon
restaurant catalan vous avez de la fidoa
vous avez la cargolade aussi sont les
escargots à l'ayolioui ah oui ça base
d'ayoli quand même toujours avec de
l'ail quoi mais c'est un peu comme
Beatles RollingStone alors vous hormis
votre épouse qu'est-ce que vous préférez
fondamentalement une bonne Paila ou une
bonne fidwa ah moi je je crois que avec
le temps je préfère la filoire ah
d'accord mais c'est vrai c'est quand
elle est un peu croustillante comme ça
quand elle gr parce que en fait ce sont
des plats qui sont sec Brigit il y a un
peu de bouillon pu ensuite on les met au
four non mais on les met au four quand
je veux dire ils sècheent contrairement
à un risoto ou un riz avec un peu de
sauce c'est gratiné un peu il y a pas de
fromage mais il y a du cramat dans dans
le dans le fond ce qu'on appelle quand
c'est alors moi ce que j'aime aussi
c'est les riz les alrosses aussi c'est
fabuleux ça les Espagnols savent très
bien faire et votre femme elle a cette
petite ce petit poilon parce que ça
c'est indispensable he oui elle a le
poilon
elle a pas que ça
visiblement c'est quoi il y a une
recette familiale qui prépare la fidoa
bah c'est surtout sa mère c'est surtout
sa mère surtout sa mère qui sait très
très bien cuisiner ma femme elle a
d'autres sujets d'intérêt mais bon donc
elle elle a pas récupéré la recette et
ça c'est plutôt quand vous allez chez
votre belle-mère elle na ni récupéré la
recette ni récupéré l'envie en
fait cuisiner c'est plutôt moi qui
cuisine ou dire vous savez le la
préparer j'ai j'ai j'en ai fait une une
fois mais mais pas bon voilà ça a été
assez rare mais c'est vrai que je
cuisine toujours dans le respect du du
produit bien entendu qu'est-ce qu'est-ce
qui est difficile parce que je sais que
c'est difficile une F qu'est-ce qui est
difficile pour vous à réussir chaque
étape chaque étap de la patience il faut
regarder savoir à quel moment on met le
bouillon à quel moment on rajoute les
pâtes à quel moment voilà tout doit être
fait dans un timing qui est assez
contraignant c'est assz fascinant
toujours un mariage le lendemain du
mariage il y avait une énorme d'une amie
de ma femme il y avait une énorme comme
ça un énorme poil long et puis il y
avait une le cuisinier le chef était là
avec son bâton comme ça pour cétait
c'est c'est une vraie une vraie
tradition un vrai rituel et je suis
surpris quand en Espagne ils font des
énormes pa là on se dit ça va pas être
très bon c'est pas possible cette pa
elle fait quasiment 10 m de diamètre la
poil et ils arrivent à faire des bonnes
pa sont B et alors vous dites je
travaille dans le respect du du produit
qu'est-ce que vous faites si vous êtes
en cuisine qu'est-ce que pouvez n
préparer je suis pas un un grand
cuisinier puis souvent j'ai pas le temps
ouais c'est pour ça que dans dans le
livre là j'ai recueilli quelques
quelques recettes un peu faciles ou
voilà ça c'est le livre don dont on va
parler après mais tournée générale ma
route des vins on va on va en reparler
mais il y a des recettes effectivement
de cuisine à l'intérieur c'est oui ce
sont des choses assez simples
finalement mais c'est vrai moi je pars
du produit vraiment voilà je fais
souvent griller et là-bas il faont
griller aussi vraiment c'est comme ça on
va faire griller après l'apéro grill
l'huile d'olive l'huile d'olive donc une
viande un poisson grillé comme oui une
viande un poisson grillé voilà ça c'est
vraiment des choses que j'adore moi
j'aime bien grignoter j'aime bien la
tapass quand il y a plein de choses sur
la table moi ça j'adore ça vous êtes
très gourmand c'est ça oui c'est ça
j'aime bien déguster comme pour les vins
j'aime bien boire un verre et puis après
tout de suite goûter un autre vin et
puis comme ça j'aime bien la la
curiosité finalement aussi anime
exctement la culture on en a parlé déjà
dans cette émission la culture du tapass
c'est pas très français en Catalogne
quand même côté français ça existe par
capilarité par pass c'est un art de
vivre le capasse aussiou ou oui moi
j'aime bien j'aime bien ça j'aime on
passe de bar en bar on boit un coup
c'est ça moi j'ai du mal à m'enfermer
dans un plat VO
voilà et et la fingerfot ça vous plaît
aussiadore pour moi la fingerfot c'est
vraiment le l'héritière de la de la de
la tapace quoi de la formule tapace quoi
c'est il y a plein de petites choses on
peut grignoter boire un petit verre et
puis comme vous dites aller de barre en
barre avec ma femme on appelle ça le
Baraton c'estd qu'on fait un verre un
bar un verre un bar et comme ça ça nous
per permet de de se balader un peu de
voilà de déambuler de déambuler puis au
bout de TR trois barres on a
l'impression d'avoir fait la tournée des
grands ducs on avoir fait une soirée
extraordinaire ah bah 42 km de bar ça
fait quelques c'est ça ça s'appelle un
marathon oui c'est ça et alors donc vous
avez il y a la finger foot bien sûr mais
il y a aussi le grignotage sans arrêt
enfin vous êtes du genre à manger un peu
toute la journée ou pas non non là
j'essaie de me de me contenir un peu eu
égard cet emploi de jeune premier que
j'ai encore au cinéma jeune romantique
j'essaie de maintenir non non je suis
très gourmand et donc il faut il faut
voilà faut se donner quelques règles
j'essaie de manger assez peu le matin de
pas grignoter dans la journée mais mais
quand vient l'heure de laapéro je peux
pas m'empêcher
de c'est le moment on se détend un peu
on boit un petit verre de blanc c'est
sympa on a bien compris que votre femme
vous Z complètement converti au
catalanisme mais alors la cuisine
française mince avec deux maisons c'est
un nom français ça ça fait ça pense on
fait pense à la blanquette au BF est-
que vous aimez les totem de la cuisine
française mon plat préféré c'est la
blanquette le guign j'adore ça quand il
est V quand il est bien fondant oui du
bourgogne quand il est bien fondant
quand il voilà quand j'adore oui j'adore
fromageme vous êtes un bon vivant direou
oui j'ai beaucoup d'amis chefs
restaurateursve d' exactement j
gougeoint Sophie pque il y a aussi
pierre Herm mon ami pâtissier non c'est
c'est une vraie une vraie passion la
table c'est une vraie passion oui
vraiment et alors vous faites votre
marché un petit peu vous allez choisir
vos produits en fonction de de des
saisons du bio tout ça ou non là je sens
un peu de Oui Oui on essaie on essaie de
se faire quand on est dans le sud on
essaie de se faire livré par les
agriculteurs du coin notre cagette en
début de semaine avec que les produits
de saison que des légumes de saison et
et c'est vrai que là aussi c'est
merveilleux de de de de mettre des
aubergines au four avec un peu de de
sauce misau c'est c'est c'est délicieux
c'est c'est tout simple il suffit
d'avoir un bon produit pour souvent
avoir un bon plat alors il y a un pays
qui est connu pour ces bons produits
c'est l'île de beauté l'île Corse vous
avez des racines corses on on en parlera
au dessert mais quand même quand vous
faites de la cuisine salée vous pensez
vos racines corses de temps en temps
elles vous titill et sortez des bien
entendu qu'est-ce que vous nous faites
côté Corse si on VI chez vous côté Corse
vous avez le les beigners de brut voilà
ils sont extraordinaire le grand
classique vous avez les beignets de
brouge vous avez les bah le oui le
fiadon le dessert don vous avez tout ce
qui est pollen tu as tout ce qui est
voilà il y a ces plat traditionnels
Corse que aussi oui cor fromage corse
qui sont à tombé les 20 cors qui sont
merveilleux comment on appelle le jambon
Corse le le prout voilà le prout là
c'est c'est réservé aux cors les
touristes pensent ils ont jamais droit
parce qu'ils ont produisent pas assez
pour pour fournir toute la demande et
les cuisine du monde ça vous intéresse
aussi enfin en ce moment vous il y a des
cuisines que vous vous aimez
particulèement on vers l'Asie je sais
pas si j'adore la cuisine asiatique en
fait je suis gourmand donc et curieux
donc j'adore la cuisine asiatique mon
mon mon père a vécu au Vietnam pendant
des années donc il y a une vraie culture
de la cuisine asiatique à la maison on a
beaucoup d'amis asiatiques donc voilà
donc petit il y avait à à la mais petit
on allait mon grand-père ne mangeait que
de la cuisine asiatique d'accord
beaucoup de riz aussi ou beaucoup à base
de riz oui enfin de des cuisines
vietnamiennes cambodenors le for on
était des des amateurs de Fort de
[Musique]
boboun avant que ce soit à la mode final
de de oui oui non non de on est
exactement on est on a toujours baigné
dans cette dans cette cuisine je me
souviens de de de moment avec mon
grand-père où on allait dans des petits
restaurants comme ça dans le 13e des
petits petits restaurant chinois dans le
13e sur la dalle il y avait une ambiance
incroyable c'est les meilleurs sur la
dalle là-bas dans le 13 exactement
exactement et la cuisine japonaise aussi
les sushis très à la mode très à la mode
on a des très bons sushi à Paris
aujourd'hui la cuisine japonaise et puis
les bento aussi il y a pas que il y pas
que la cuisine il y a pas que les sushi
la cuisine japonaise a plein d'autres
spécialités c'est une cuisine d'une
finesse incroyable non moi je crois que
je suis assez assez grand public je suis
assez ouvert d'esprit universel exaement
quand vous partez en vacances est-ce que
la cuisine du pays c'est un moteur qui
permet de d'orienter votre destination
bien sûr bien sûr quand préférer au
Vietnam qu'en Islande si on parle de la
bouffe oui exactement moi je suis une
vra je suis une vraie éponge donc c'est
que quand j'arrive par exemple à Venise
avec ma femme pendant 4 jours je vais
parler comme ça avec italien ma chérie
peut plus bon et puis oui on va se faire
des risotos je je me souviens d'un
risotto métropole vitello un risotto
vitello avec avec un vin de
Quintarelli Val poolitella classico de
Giuseppe Quintarelli ça a été un moment
suspendu c'était tellement bon que le
lendemain on est retourné au même
endroit pour manger ex et boire
exactement la même chose ah oui ah oui
c'est rare ça de de retourner
l bon on se voit pas mieux que ce
miracle attention si votre femme vous
écoute parce que là vous êtes en train
de me dire que la cuisine italienne
meilleure concurrence la cuisine
catalane sérieusement euh oui alors
écoutez je ne sais pas c'est différent
c'est voilà je cherche pas mais c'est
vrai qu' à Paris aujourd'hui bon il y a
quatre restaurants italiens par rue
ouais pour pour un restaurant espagnol
il y en a très très peu oui il y en a
assez peu des restaurants espagnol une
vraie culture une vraie gastronomie qu
moua c'est vrai c'est vrai et alors vous
êtes plutôt biserau étoilé cuisine du
monde qu qu'est-ce
qui tout je suis tout je suis tout
j'adore les petits bistr ou euh j'adore
les les et puis j'ai oui je vous dis
j'ai j'ai une appétence aussi de temps
en temps aller chez un grand chef un
grand créateur un artiste pour moi ce
sont des artistes ces gens-là mais vous
connaissons un peu vous aimez les
gueuletons les copains les amis vous
êtes quand même plus à l'aise dans les
bistr où ça chante ou
ça non mais parfois c'est vrai que il y
a un peu de protocole un peu de code
dans les étoilées donc ça ça vous il y a
d'ailleurs dans mon dans mon spectacle
il y a un moment où vous avez un serveur
qui arrive et qui va comme ça parler d'
plat et je dis souvent il vous parle
comme si vous étiez en face terminale ou
nous sommes sur une escabèche d'écrevis
puis nous irons sur un pigeonau farci à
la chéux de crabe d'Alaska revenu dessus
dessous dans un jus de cerise grillotte
accompagné de Safine galette de Sarasin
cuite à la vapeur d'un géser du désert
du serérenetti et là on ne sait pas ce
qu'on va trouver dans l'assiette oui
c'est ça c'est c'est mais c'est un
rituel c'est aussi assez théâtral
finalement parce que moi mes premières
émotions quand mes parents pour fêter un
bac ou une un diplôme m'emmener c'était
un peu le rituel m'emmenait dans un
grand restaurant euh qui était beaucoup
plus accessible qu'aujourd'hui hein faut
pas se mentir et ben il m'emmenait il y
avait ce rituel de des serveurs de
l'ambiance de ça m'a tout de suite
fasciné ce côté très théâtral des des
grandes maisons mais c'est une
expérience d'ailleurs regardez vous en
souvenez vous vous nous racontez ce
qu'on vous a dit pour accompagner votre
plat donc c'est que ça vous a marqué
quand même donc c'est réussi exactement
je crois que c'est c'est c'est ça aussi
qui est qui est formidable c'est que le
service et j'ai beaucoup d'admiration
pour les métiers de la salle aussi son
le service a aussi son importance c'est
le le fond la forme voilà comment on va
vous parler d'un vin comment on va vous
parler d'un plat c'est la façon dont on
va vous en parler qui va vous vous
donner l'envie vous guider comme quand
on visite un musée d'art contemporain et
qu'à côté de nous on a passionné qui va
vous dire tu sais là c'est c'est le
moment de sa vie où voilà Jackson
Pollock n'a plus d'argent il doit
peindre sur son lit et cetera voilà par
exemple oui ah oui quand vous allez au
au au MoMA à New York vous vous avez le
un lit de jackton Pollock qui l'a peint
avec ses bon sa méthode particulière son
génie quoi de lancer et au cinéma par
exemple il vous arrive souvent d'avoir
des scènes où vous mangez comment ça se
passe alors au cinéma c'est très très
c'est c'est c'est très alors c'est très
chiant les scènes au cinéma parce que il
faut pas faire faux quoi faut pas être
comme dans C série américaine où ils ont
les ils ont une pomme pu après la pomme
c'est le déjeuner non c'est pas c'est
pas réaliste il faut y aller quoi ouais
bon alors c'est pas la grand on tourne
pas la Grande Bouffe tous les jours non
plus mais bon au début vous êtes très
content ouais quand il faut faire la
prise 15 fois c'est plus compliqué donc
on remet des choses dans l'assiette on
recommence on oui mais c'estd que faut
être à corord c'est par exemple si je
fais ça comme ça ah oui je vous parle si
ça marche pas c'est paraccord donc il
faut remettre la même quantité de FID
bah oui VO do remettre la même quantité
sinon c'est fait faux ouais si je vais
comme ça on y croit plus non non ça va
pas ah oui donc à la fin on a plus du
tout envie de manger on a plus du tout
envie de faire la prise 15 alors on
s'affame généralement c'estàd qu'on ne
mange pas la cantine quand c'est
l'après-midi on arrive sur le plateau en
ayant un peu de réserve que si vous
sortez de table et que on vous sert un
gratin alors moi je je peux contourner
le truc de temps en temps je je fais
comme si je j'essaie de dire mes phrases
sans avoir mangé oui parce qu'en plus
c'est pas très facile de manger de
parler en même temps non exactement
alors on va voir si vous êtes vraiment
incollable c'est le
quiz vous avez joué dans le film Le
Petit Nicolas le rôle de bouillon
Brigitte l'a précisé tout à l'heure de
son vrai nom monsieur Dubon surveillant
de l'école de Nicolas surnommé ainsi car
il dit souvent regardez-moi bien dans
les yeux et dans le bouillon comme on le
sait il y a des yeux sauriez-vous nous
dire qu' a eu cette autre citation à
propos du bouillon la cuisine française
doit sa supériorité à l'excellence de
son bouillon à Paul bocus feu Paul bocus
l'un des grands papes de la gastronomie
française Alexandre Duma Auguste
Escoffier ou Louis de funess qui on sait
à tourner dans des films où il était
question plus ou moins de restaurant il
a le grand restaurant il y a
eu je crois que c'est Auguste Escoffier
et bien non c'est Alexandre Duma dans
son grand dico de cuisine voilà bravo
bon alors on peut se rattraper deuxème
coup vous me nourrissez aussi de culture
je vous remci par votre mère vous avez
du sangcorse on l'a dit î du fameux brut
ce fromage de chè de brebis alors ses
affirmations concernant le Broch
sont-elles vrai
comment vous dites BR
BR vraie ou fausse alors ces
affirmations c'estelles vraie ou fausse
ah contrairement au BR le BR Corse est
protégé par une AOC attention pi BR
Corse est protégé par une AOC mais si si
vous donnez la réponse l' c'est pas
possible non j'ai dit qu'il y avait un
piège il y a un piège et bien et bien
non et ben c'est faux c'est vrai c'est
vrai il y a une alors faux il s'agit du
même fromage donc c'est la même chose
voilà c'est c'est un piège bon donc le
Broch et le BR c'est la même chose voilà
donc ouioui j'avais pas compris la
question voilà bah ou je crois je
croyais que le brut était protégé par
une AOC non contrairement au Broch le
Broch Corse est protégé par pas compris
la question donc il aurit répondu pas
d'Oc j'aurais répondu bon si il y a une
AOC mais comme c'est le même fromage il
y a pas une différence entre le botch
cosos qui a une AOC et le Broch normal
d'cord donc il y a une AOC ou on est
bien d'accord donc j'avais faux de toute
façon voilà soyons honnête allez le
cousin italien du brut et la fontina
faux faux c'est la ricota bien joué dans
la cuisine corse on farce même les
sardines au brut faux vrai oui
vrai sardine j'ai décidé de répondre
faux faux à tout dans le mois idéal pour
se régaler d'un brochch frais et août
faux
faux octobre à juin oui voilà ça il
Savit c'est comme le figatel c'est
saisonier aussi h Mang un Fatel ple de
mois de juillet c'est pas voilà
ouais ça c'est pas ça se fait pas quoi
alors vous savez que c'est souvent à
l'occasion d'un déjeuner que se nou les
deals politiques que se fait la petite
et la grande Histoire et c'est la breève
de
comptoir alors François Xavier de maison
vous a demandé de réfléchir à une
anecdote non mais manger tranquillement
à une anecdote autour d'un d'un d'un
repas en politique éventuellement si
vous aviez est-ce que vous avez une
petite petite anecdote à nous raconter
c'est une anecdote de tournage mais qui
est qui est voilà ce que on avait
préparé la pendant la pause déjeuner on
était avec Benois Magimel André vims on
avait préparé une scène de cascade ah et
donc on on déjeunait tous les trois et
le cascadeur vient notre table et nous
dit vous inquiétez pas la la sécurité
c'est ma
priorité très bien tant mieuxureusement
et voilà donc je je devais moi dans la
scène assommer tuer André Wims en lui
éclatant une carafe de sucre sur le
crâne la sécurité c'est ma priorité on
termine notre notre plat on se on se
vait légèrement voilà raccorder on
arrive sur le plateau et donc je
m'engueule avec avec André je saisis la
la carafe de sucre et je lui éclate sur
la tête il s'effondre on entend
oh quel acteur enfin la performance est
incroyable André Andr ça va ça va et en
fait le la la la carafe n'avait pas
explosé
elle s'était figée et il avait le pauvre
était ouvert de là jusque là avec une
espèce de crête de de de de sucre
defin de de la
priorité et là je revois le cascadeur
qui regarde la carafe et qui fait je
comprends pas je comprends pas donc
voilà une petite anecdote de tournage ah
oui mais sinon il allait bien non il est
parti à l'hôpital vous avez pas ah oui
il a été transporté là voilà on mais la
scène était bonne en fait al dans le
film c'est celle qui a été montée voilà
on a pu en tourner qu'une he oui c'est
ça il a pas voulu refaire l'expérience
une deuxième fois ah il pouvait pas je
pense qu'il a été voilà ah ben elle est
rigolote la coleluche très bien alors
vous savez que dans cette émission on
mange mais on on boit aussi alors on a
décidé vous nous avez demander un vin du
du Roussillon mais oui pour accompagner
cette fidoa forcément c'est c'est
cohérent vous avez effectivement vous un
domaine dans l'ousillon donc j'imagine
que vous connaissez bien cette cette
région alors on va pas faire une
dégustation totalement à l'aveugle he
vous avez c'est un V rouge il est du
Rousillon donc je vous donne quand même
une petite une petite information mais
si on fait une dégustation à l'aveugle
est-ce que vous sauriez dire un peu moi
je excellent moi mais moi
aussi
HM magnifique ah non c'est très très
beau je pense que ce sont des sépages
autochtones al c'est Roussillon hein
c'est Roussillon oui donc CIRA
grenachemour vert he c'est ça P les
spages ou ouais avec un léger
vieillissement barique
voilà
voilà la spécial du vin c'est Brigitte
alors et alors vous avez pas d'idée
particulière non il me fait un peu
penser à à ce qu'on fait dans notre
région je vous avoue banda voilà c'est
vrai oui bon ben c'est si belle ah ben
voilà c'est si belle der mandat donc
c'est votre domaine alors vous pouvez
peut-être nous en parler encore un petit
peu m on le félicite parce à l'avol il a
reconnu son 20 il a il aurait pu se
planter effectivement donc vous avez bon
goût dans cette émission
non mais ça aurait été difficile sinon
là c'est un millésime 2020 oui voilà qui
est en vente actuellement donc grenage
Shira
effectivement fruité alors des goûts de
cerises de cassiss légèrement vanillé
c'est en appellation vin de France et
donc la région on est en on est en
langdoc Roussillon exactement alors nous
dans notre gamme on a le le grand la
Grande Cuvée ce qu'on appelle voilà qui
est en côte du Roussillon et là la
Sibelle c'est une on est en vinde France
parce que ça nous permet de faire les
assemblages un peu rigolo et alors il y
a un assemblage très étrange on a mis un
tout petit peu de vin blanc c'est ça et
on a le droit on a le droit en V France
vous avez le droit de mettre un petit
peu de voilà au dernier moment oui ah ça
je savais pas au dernier moment c'est
pas un kir he c'est pas au moment de
serv bien sûr non mais c'est ce que
c'est ce que je lais au moment de le
mettre en barique avant ah oui qu'il y a
des Carignan noirs sont vinifiés avec
des grenages blancs vionniers et
chardonnés exactement et tout ça fait
que c'est il y a ce résultat c'estd que
vous avez ce côté un petit peu oui cette
cette petit du lait en fin de
bouche et et ça son on peut se le
permettre en main de France toéré vous
savez beaucoup de grands vignerons du
sud de la France sont sortis de
l'appellation pour les secours à leur
inspiration et à leur à leur génie par
exemple si je pense à Elois durbac qui
avait le domaine trèsvallon dans les
Bouches du rô bon voilà il est sorti de
l'appellation Provence ça lui a permis
de mettre du Cabernet dans sa Sira et
d'arriver à ses assemblages assez
extraordinaires ouais c'est ça mais ça
veut dire qu'on crée toujours on a cet
esprit-là parce que sinon quand on reste
dans des appellations classiques des
grandes appellations on se retrouve avec
toujours les mêmes spages exactement
mais après ça a du bon quand vous êtes
en Bourgogne quand vous êtes voilà donc
il y a des appellations non je crois qu'
ce sont deux écoles c'est à un moment
donné faire des vins où on est dans
l'appellation et dans le cahier des
charges on est fidèle à un terroir
fidèle à à l'appellation et puis et puis
des cuvés où on peut s'amuser un petit
peu et aller aller voilà ça c'est euh
Dominique Laporte avec qui vous
travaillez VO c'est mon associé qui est
Dominique Laporte meilleur somelier de
France et on a voilà on a créé ce
domaine il y a 5 ans alors on va
continuer à parler du vin bien sûr
puisque derrière une bonne fidéoa ce qu'
généralement un bon vin et c'est le
dessous des
plats alors vous le professionnel du vin
vous savez que le dérèglement climatique
a des conséquences importantes sur la
vigne ça a donné des idées à certains
planter du raisin dans des régions
jusqu'ici pas assez chaudes comme dans
les haut de France le premier millésime
vient de sortir de terre une dégustation
proposée par Hélène Bonduel et Marion de
Vauchel alors on est dans la parcelle de
vigne qu'on a planté il y a maintenant 3
ans et c'est le grand jour de la
vendange on se croirait dans le sud
pourtant nous sommes bien dans le nord
de la France début octobre et il fait
encore 25 degr c'est une récolte
particulière pour ses bénévoles sur
cette parcelle pour la première fois ils
vont vendanger es sont lourdes pleine de
soleil le soleil des haut de France dans
les grappes ah oui dans les grappes
franchement c'est extraordinaire
j'aurais jamais cru ça ça fait 25 ans
que j'habite ici et j' jamais j'aurais
cru qu'on aurait eu des des vignes et
qu'on puisse faire le vin il y a un peu
une mutation avec le climat bon c'est un
bien un mal je sais pas on verra la
suite hein bon après il y a un cycle
normal de du réchauffement hein donc on
verra faut s'adapter à la fois bien
s'adapter a des sols qui changent avec
le réchauffement climatique c'est ce que
Julien den a fait il a abandonné une
partie de ses céréales pour se consacrer
à la vigne c'était pas rentable on était
limité au niveau rendement et voilà les
cultures se plaisaient pas dans ces terr
là c'est un petit challenge aussi un
gros challenge c'est c'est découvrir une
notre culture découvrir de A à Z on a
tout à apprendre alors le céréalier
devenu vigneron séè du collectif des 130
des industriels et des vignerons qui se
sont lancés dans le projet il y a 3 ans
c'est dit qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait faire
pour
améliorer la diversification et en même
temps on avait le réchauffement
climatique qui devenait de plus en plus
prignant sur la région et donc on a
commencé à regarder cette
diversification actuellement il y a 90
hectares qui qui sont plantés avec une
bonne cinquantaine d'agriculteurs qui
sont concernés objectif 200 he de Vig
d'ici 5 ans dans le Nord le vin lui un
chardonnis est assemblé ici dans cette
ancienne
sucrerie la première sensation c'est un
vin qui est assez explosif du un côté
perlant donc qui prend vraiment de
l'ampleur dans la bouche donc c'est
vraiment un vin destiné pour les
apéritifs on est très porté sur les
agrumes jaunes et sur les agrumes rouges
tels que le pamplemousse deux cuvés sont
commercialisé la troisème le sera l'an
prochain on est très content de des
produits que nous avons par pour un
premier millésime ça c'est une
perspective d'avenir
assez assez gratifiante parce que quand
on arrive à voir cette qualité avec des
viines qui n'ont seulement 3 ans on sait
que quand elles auront entre 8 et 10 ans
on sera leur plein potentiel on va dire
qualitatif et ça sera pour de longues
années donc on aura pas à rougir de la
qualité qu'on aura derrière mais pour le
moment le vin du Nord reste un marché de
niche moins de 5000 bouteilles vendues
uniquement dans la
région alors là c'est le premier mésim
effectivement dans les EAU DE FRANCE
mais vous pensez que demain et bien le
vin sera essentiellement planté dans la
partie nord de la France en tout cas le
réchauffement climatique a des conséquen
voilà concrète hein c'est c'est le cas
aussi en Normandie en belgiqueag c'est
goûteré des vins oui j'ai goûté les vins
en Belgique très bon euh oui
effectivement tout ça évolue les les
toutes les ce réchauffement climatique a
des conséquences à court terme
sympathique positives et puis bon à
moyen terme et long terme plus plus
inquiétant mais vous vous le voyez par
exemple chez vous à mirmanda ce ce
réchauffement c'est-à-dire que vous avez
des des degrés d'alcool qui sont
beaucoup plus importants vous avez une
grosse sécheresse mais nos vignes sont
plantées on cette chance là sont des
très vieilles vignes qu'on plus de 80
ans et qui sont plantés dans la vallée
de laaglie vous avez une espèce de
rivière souterraine donc en terme de de
voilà d'hydrique les ah oui nos vignes
voilà mais c'est un vrai problème on
produit entre le Milu euh et et la
sécheresse on produit de de moins en
moins de vin c'est vre votre récolte se
réduit notre récolte se réduit et les
ouais les BA sont moins gorgé de ou de
oui c'est c'est surtout surtout l'année
dernière mais enfin l'année d'avant
l'année dernière enfin avec le vin qu'on
qu'on met en bouteille aujourd'hui voilà
mais
c'est ça fait partie des de de voilà
l'homme doit s'adapter et vous vous
adaptez par exemple vous ombragez un peu
vos vignes ou non rien du tout non pas
du tout pas du tout
droit de faire du gout à gout
on en fait pas du tout pas du tout pas
du tout je vous dis ce sont des vieilles
dames de 80 ans qui qui ont besoin de
personne 80 ans c'est vieux pour des
vigesine euh ben ça peut aller bien
au-delà 100 ans 120 ans c'est déjà pas
mal je suis profan je savais pas oui ça
fait déjà pas mal pour un
humain beau SEP de vigne bien tordu mais
est-ce que ça veut dire que ce vin
confidentiel de Julien un jour ce sera
votre con confidentiel il font quand
même 50000 bouteilles oui mais
confidentiel c'est vin du Nord pour
l'instant oui est-ce que ça sera votre
concurrent de demain finalement est-ce
que c'est mon concurrent je sais pas
parce que de toute façon le Roussillon
est une région qui qui est qui est
récente sur les enfin voilà en terme
d'image elle elle a elle est pas récente
je dirais au niveau histoire et et
viticulture mais elle est elle est
devenue à la mode récemment comme c'est
vin du rô bon voilà ce sont des régions
qui ont longtemps comment on dit fait
cracher la vigne et qui aujourd'hui VOA
voilà et aujourd'hui il y a des
domainestraord c'est c'est traville de
manière extraordinaire si je pense à
djouanessi si je pense à gardess Gobi r
des anges sont des domaines
exceptionnel qui sont sur les plus
grandes tables parisiennes ou ou même à
l'étranger donc j'ai envie de dire que
c'est une région qui vient de qui qui
perce là en ce moment la sécheresse
c'est vrai que c'est un problème vaut
mieux peut-être aller planter des vignes
en Alsace ou en norm mais alors c'est
vrai qu'on dit qu'un vin c'est il y a
pas il y a pas que la il y a pas que le
raisin il y a aussi le terroir il y a
les sols est-ce qu'on on retrouve ça a
hommes la façon dont il le travaill mais
les hommes ils peuvent aller dans les
haut Frances mais les sols est-ce queon
va retrouver vous vous êtes plutôt sur
du calcaire je pense argil calcaire ou
estce que sur du granit on va planter
enfin on va avoir les mêmes terroir pour
avoir des bonnes vignes oui je pense je
pense que c'est il faut il faut attendre
un peu de voir ce que ça va donner sur
le temps mais c'est l'homme qui
aujourd'hui vous savez on dit souvent la
nature fait du vinaigre et l'homme fait
du vin c'est c'est la personnalité d'un
vigneron sa passion son exigence qui va
faire que on va avoir aussi un
résultat suite regarder le beaujolet
voilà vous avez Marcel Lapierre qui a
été un véritable pionnier qui a tranché
un petit peu avec toute cette culture du
beaujolet nouveau et aujourd'hui en
beaujolet vous avez des artistes des
vins exceptionnels des Gamet avec une
floraison comme ça une un floral dans
dans c'est des bouquets de fleurs c'est
vin rouge de de aujourd'hi fleur Méra
les côtes de P de chez toyard voilà c
magnifique oui mais Brigitte les hommes
on est vigorant de père en fils de
grand-père il y a des des des traditions
qui remonte à plusieurs générations mais
là on voit bien c'est un séréalié qui se
met au vin il y a pas de tradition
derrire il y a pas d'homme oui mais bon
je pense qu'il le fait pas tout seul
tout seul
s on pas tradition de V c'est vrai c'est
vrai que dans dans le Bordelet il y a
des gens qui font du vin depuis 400 ans
donc c'est diff difficile d'arriver
ensuite mais je pense que sur une
production plus plus confidentielle et
voilà ils peuvent arriver à des
résultats sympas et voilà alors
justement alors ils nous ont donné une
bouteille pour justement vous faire goû
rien que le nez me plaît beaucoup ça
vous plaît ah oui beaucoup mais vous
vous êtes fan de Chardonnet de toute
façon bah c'est le c'est pas
extraordinaire bon à consommer avec
modération bien sûr alors Brigit oui oui
il est très bon je l'ai goûté avant
c'est pour ça mais
ou là là on a faire un connaisseur moi
je je sais pas faire ces bruitages mais
moi je le trouve bon mais je suis très
bon bon bon oui oui c'est très floral
effectivement il y a des agrumes il ce
côté c'est très agréable très très
agréable mais bravo bravo le Nord le vin
du Nord donc effectivementin Nord
premier vin du Nord François Xavier a
raison il faut s'en réjouir parce que
c'est sympa pour ces viguron du Nord
mais si on s'en rjit trop c'est quand
même une mauvaise nouvelle pour la
planète parce que ça veut dire qu'on
peut on va pouvoir faire bientôt du vin
en Écosse et au Grenland donc c'est pas
terrible pas arrêent pas whis les
Écossais moi ça me va alors comment elle
est comment il est né en fait comment
est née l'histoire de ce livre où on
parle beaucoup de vin o on voit souvent
un verre à la main avec euh avec des
amis avec euh euh des chefs des
someliers et cetera c'est c'est c'est
c'est l'idée c'est que en fait je suis
parti euh je viens d'avoir 50 ans et je
me suis dit il faut que je réalise ce
rêve de prendre ma route des vins et d'
d'aller à la rencontre de tous ces amis
que j'ai passionnés par le vin par ses
régions alors voilà vous avez guilem de
Cal qui est un un sommelier qui cartonne
sur les réseaux sociaux
h et qui est journaliste culinaire vous
avez voilà je vais aller goûter des
midjaville avec mon ami Stéphane degot
la là on arrive dans le domaine mirmanda
justement dans le sud du côté du cirque
de ving gros avec Dominique la porte on
va aller à la rencontre d'annne Sophie
pque dans le rô et puis on va aller
déguster chez leurentcbier huganglof des
côterotties et des des
crossermitages on va aller en Alsace
chez Philippe blanc qui est un véritable
passionné goûter des vins du jurat avec
Stéphane tissau chez Thierry Germain la
Loire qui est une sorte de prêtre de la
biodynamie voilà c'est à chaque fois des
donc on est dans toutes les régions de
France exactement on voyage dans toutes
ces régions de France à la rencontre de
passionnés et de et de gens qui vont
nous parler de transmission de de leur
passion de leur métier de leur doutes de
leur de leur prise de risque c'est un
peu une petite encyclopédie du vin non
parce qu'il y a beaucoup d'infos Mo
quand on le feuillette comme ça qui lu
CR anecdotes des reces ouais il y a des
y a des petites oui il a des petites
questions à la con ce qu'on appelle
question à la con ou mais ça on est
toujours content des petites questions
mais alors j'allais dire l'picurien le
jouisseur parce qu'on on a déjà passé 40
minutes à table avec vous on a compris
qui vous êtes hein vous aimez non mais
c'est vrai mais alors vous êtes vous
aimez les gueuletons vous aimez la bonne
chair vous êtes pas un peu fatigué de
cette période où chaque excès est un peu
sanctionné limité ou euh c'est pas un
problème pour vous je sais pas si chaque
excès est limité en tout cas il y a des
il y a des il y a des convictions pour
moi qui sont compatibles c'est-à-dire
que euh il y a je je comprends tout à
fait euh quand les gens qui sont
végétariens je comprends tout à fait les
mouvements de de conscientisation de ce
qu'on mange et je les respecte
énormément voilà quand un boucher
effectivement que je connais me dit moi
tu sais c'est une bête par
semaine c'est tout euh c'est c'est de ça
que je vis et je respecte mes animaux et
je les nourris bien ils sont à l'air
j'ai pas envie de lui jeter la pierre à
cet Hommel je dire bravo et donc moi
c'est vrai que je mange moins de viande
ah oui vous aussi vous avez adapté votre
mais mais mais elle est meilleure ou
donc je crois que c'est bien le 0 km
c'est c'est parfait c'est mon mon lo
voilà c'est mon voisin qui vient me
livrer ma ma cagette de de de de de
légumes oubliés alors certains légumes
oubliés on comprend pourquoi ils les ont
oubliés aussi et on n pas envie de les
faire revenir au du jour voilà fa
continuons à les oublier oui c'est ça
mais je crois que c'est c'est sain et et
ça va dans le bon sens effectivement les
dogmes les excès les les les les les les
les sectaires ça ça ça c'est c'est un
peu gonflant c'est sûr mais c'est vrai
que souvent on a du mal à voir euh la
personne qui mange moins de viande moins
de moins de euh moins moins de poisson
euh qui qui se concentre sur les légumes
on a l'impression que c'est moins
gourmand que euh que qu'on prend moins
de plaisir autour de la table alors moi
j'ai j'ai je suis parti en weekend avec
des gens qui sont végétariens et on
s'est absolument régalé hein voilà
c'était délicieux c'est vrai qu'il faut
faut faut dire ce qu'il est on était on
était très léger pendant tout le weekend
on a mangé des plats qui étaient des
légumes qui étaient cuits à la
perfection avec des épices c'était
merveille aussi donc voilà il faut dire
que c'est pas forcément triste forcment
TR je crois que ça dépend avec qui on on
pratique c'est voilà et on partage aussi
exactement alors il y a aussi votre
votre spectacle qui s'appelle divin
voilà on y revient il est très 20 quand
même oui al c'est pas divin c'est 10 20
alors non alors ça peut être divin aussi
ça peut être divin aussi c'est un
prétexte là c'est vraiment un prétexte
la band on ve voilà c'est comme la bande
originale de ma vie en fait c'estd que
je vais me servir de d'une ou de d'une
bouteille pour ramener un souvenir c'est
une madeleine de prou en fait et
effectivement ça me permet de d'aller
chercher les souvenirs d'enfance d'aller
voyager dans le temps dans l'espace
c'est une équation à plein entrée le le
V par exemple vous vos souvenirs c'est
souvent une bouteille qui les accompagne
en tout cas j'ai voulu ce prétexte là
parce que voilà ça aurait pu être la
bande originale de ma vie avec des
musiques ou des films et là j'ai trouvé
que le 20in ça me correspondait bien et
je trouvais qu'après cette longue
période de distanciation il était temps
de se retrouver comme j'ai créé ce
spectacle juste après le confinement
c'était une voilà une envie se retrouver
autour d'un ver je trouvais ça convivial
et donc j'ai j'ai utilisé ce prétexte
des bouteilles pour voyager mais c'est
pas du tout un spectacle sur le vin
c'est pas du tout une conférence sur le
vin et voà sur l'amitié ou sur le part
voà exactement sur cette passion que
j'ai pour la scène depuis maintenant VO
puis aussi oui parce que fait justement
on va la regarder la bande annonz avec
plaisir ma fille elle a 16 ans depuis 2
ans elle m'appelle plus papa elle
m'appelle le sang quiète le
sang on paye des cours de math il y a
aucun résultat elle me répond on paye
des cours de gym il y a aucun résultat
toi le plus fort tu bois un coup je
t'aime mon amour j'ai l'impression de
coucher avec Francis Cabrel ici c'est le
Ruby je faire un bisou oh la France est
le pays des Lumières mais visiblement il
y a quelques ampoules qu'on
claqué voilà français Xavier de maison
divin rappelez-nous les dates alors ce
sera du 28 décembre au 13 janvier pour
les toutes dernières parisienne voilà
théâtre de l'œuvre thre de l'œuvre oui
que j'ai la joie de de diriger depuis 8
ans et puis et puis ensuite la tournée
qui qui est en ce moment là je je je
voyage beaucoup je me déplace beaucoup
et qui sera rentourné jusqu'à fin mars
et après c'est fini voilà de nouvelles
aventures sont les toutes dernièes on
peut aller vous voir et votre fille vous
inspire beaucoup visiblement Bahou vous
la connaissez pas parce que je peux vous
dire que c'est je j'aurais pu consacrer
un spectacle à ma fille elle l'a vu
qu'est-ce qu'elle en a pensé écoutez
elle elle est elle est très pudique
vis-à-vis de tout ce que je fais bon ça
l'a fait beaucoup rire ça ça voilà ça ça
l'amuse beaucoup que j'ai pu que j'ai pu
pu m'inspirer de de de de voilà de de
notre relation et de surtout de ses
sailliis permanentes quoi c'est-à-dire
que c'est vous avez du mal à suivre non
mais elle a une répartie incroyable elle
est elle a un culot me fait hurler de
rire mais vraiment quel acteur on le
voit hein vous avez vous venez d'avoir
Brigit il vient d'avoir 50 ans est-ce
que vous vieillissez comme un bon vin
c'est à vous de le dire mais moi je je
trouve qu'on on tient bien la route
quand
même alors vous avez aussi vécu à New
York on l'a dit au début de cette
émission avant 2001 euh vous travaillez
à l'époque dans la finance alors finance
oui alors j'étais euh chez Price
waterhous Coopers cétait une boîte de
conseil plutôt hein j'étais pas sur les
marchés on s'est donc intéressé au resto
américains qui furissent en France
incble au pays de la gastronomie on en
parle et on met les pieds dans le plat
[Musique]
alors bit il y a bien longtemps que le
hamburger riin a colonisé nots t ta mais
d'autres totem de la cuisine américaine
débarquent sur nos table tour d'horizon
avec Dario borgognot Marion duvuchel et
Ivana
navion qui dit nourriture américaine dit
forcément burger ce plat classique des
États-Unis se retrouve partout 80 % des
200000 restaurants en France présentent
un burger dans leur menu à Paris le
premier à l'avoir servi c'est Joe Allen
une référence depuis
1972 je suis venu il y a 30 ans c'est
une vieille institution ici voilà donc
j'amène ma fille je lui fais connaître
les bonnes adresses pas question de
parler de malbouff ici les burgers sont
fait maison la viande on l'a fait ici
elle est hachée ici c'est la bonne
viande il y a une un pourcentage de
viande et de et de gras pour que le
burger soit juicy et les tomates sont
fraîches les Pécos sont frais tout est
frais les frites sont faites maison donc
c'est pas de la malbouffe c'est juste
que c'est un burger avec frites tranche
de tomate salade pickles cornichon
et shedar sur le burger le shedar
justement on le retrouve dans un autre
grand classique de la cuisine américaine
le Mac and cheese surnom de macaroni au
fromage dans ce restaurant du 20e
arrondissement on ne sert que ça une
idée venue directement de New York City
en bas de mon bâtiment à Brooklyn donc
j'avais mec qui des Mac and cheese dire
traditionnel américain puis à force de
de discussion un jour je lu dis si un
jour je rentre en France je ferai bien
des Mac and cheese avec des fromages
français gratinés par-dessus ceux qui ne
connaissent pas du tout arrivent parfois
avec des appréhensions ouais c'est un
plat de pâte et tout et au final il
découvrent vraiment un plat avec des
vraies saveurs des vrais ingrédients
dedans et donc c'est c'est assez
agréable de pouvoir surprendre les gens
même avec un plat de pâte on va dire
basique bah écoutez je suis venu pour
faire plaisir à mon fils parce que là il
rendre du lycée il est fan de de
gastronomie américaine moi je suis fan
de gastronomie française et donc là
c'est l'union des deux ent après voilà
les la qualité des fromages enfin
l'assemblage et puis la créativité enfin
même moi j'apprécie donc on va manger
ensemble être ensemble autour de plat
américains c'était aussi l'idée de la
famille Benita ils ont créé au milieu de
Paris un dél ces restaurants typique de
la grosse pomme avec un ingrédient star
un morceau de viande bien particulier le
pastrami est une poitrine de bœuf que
l'on met en Saumur donc avec de l'eau du
sel et des épices on la laisse mariner
ensuite on la roule dans les épices on
la fume on la cuit pour la pasteuriser
et on la coupe en F tranche après
l'avoir passé en étuve il se mange
autant de pastramis à New York qu'il
peut se manger de jambon en France donc
c'est vraiment une culture très très new
yorkaise le pastrami fait pour être
emporté ces sandwiches sont très
prisés
extra super croquant super sa
des saveurs américaines appréciées par
d'ancien New Yorkais nostalgiqu n'est-ce
pas François Xavier de
maison et oui allez je les connais ça
s'appelle un flag en d'li pris la main
dans le sac sont ils sont adorables
alors une envie subite de pasastrami ce
jour-là mais c'est c'est d'abord c'est
délicieux ouis j'adore ils sont
adorables et oui effectivement vous AZ
con non non j'ai alors le pastrami oui
j'ai connu chez CADs délicatessen c'est
des délicatessen c'est c'était tenu
souvent par des juif asenas exactement
dans le dans le quartier de Lower East
Side et j'habitais pas très loin et
j'adorais aller manger mon sandwich
pastramis chez cat dai cat delcatessn
c'est l'endroit où vous savez me gryan a
un orgasme quand elle dans Quand Harry
rencontre sa ah oui ok voilà et elle
voilà donc c'est parce qu'elle mange du
pastram non
oui peut-être
aussi mais on les sert avec ses gros
concombres vous savez ces gros piicol un
peu a gros dou là les gros cornichons
oui qu'on appelle les mal au sol voilà
voilà exactement et vous mangez souvent
la Cuisine américaine à Paris ou au
contraire vous évitez un peu parce que
vous en
avez j' mais un bon burger c'est vrai
que c'est merveilleux un bon burger on
trouve à 80 dans 80 % des cartes
aujourd'hui de des rest oui c'est c'est
très bon un bon burger avec une bonne
viande bien
cuit j'ai les souvenirs de j'ai les
souvenirs quand j'allais dans les
restaurants de d'américaines qui
s'extasiaent comme ça qui était là oh my
god prend des photos c'est qu'elles
doivent faire quand même super attention
à leur lign et tout donc en fait il y a
T un dilemme dinner experience là-bas
c'est vraiment le on va chez Jean George
on va chez Daniel B ou grand
restaurateur français un des plus grand
rest ex et il y a des restaurants comme
ça qui sont mythiques à New York et mais
c'est vrai que la cuisine américaine
c'est c'est
super le fil cheesesteak aussi c'est
super le le tout ce qui est cheesecake
moi j'adore c'est non c'est super sympa
le ma je vous ai vu saliver là quand on
a vra mais là faut faut que vous me
donniez l'adresse moi je vais y aller
c'est pr du PER la chaise ah B vous les
avez entendu il disent c'est pas de la
malbouffe c'est fait maison mais bien
sûr eu le le hamburger c'est pas de la
malbouffe pas du tout
voil je suis peut-être un peu monté dans
les aiguilles avec ce pas du tout pas du
tout non c'est pas c'est pas du tout la
malbouffe c'est vra mais la ligne rouge
ça dépend si c'est de la bonne viande du
bon pain et du bon Bécon Tom voilà c'est
pas c'est fabuleux peut-être pas manger
tout les jours mais le problème c'est
que c'est quand c'est un steak
industriel du pain demi industriel salé
sur salé c'est là où ça vient de la mal
avec tout ce que ce qu' rajoute oui
effectivement dans les chaînes ouais
ouais les sauces aussi beaucoup ou je
vais vous dire peut-être honteux mais
moi le lendemain d'une grosse soirée je
suis content d'aller chercher mon McDo
mon Burger King ah ou vous rendez compte
de venir à politique pour faire
coming et à New York ce qui est bon
aussi c'est les slice de pizza pourtant
mais je sais pas pourquoi c'est
inimitable exactement c'est la Pte est
croûé un peu oui il y a quelque chose il
on grand fourev la cuisine italienne oui
mais ça c'est oui mais c'est pizza new
yorkaise oui je suis d'accord avec vous
et quand vous passez dans ces steakous
vous avez cette espèce de de graillon
végétal je sais pas ce que c'est mais
c'est délicieux bon alors vous vous êtes
plutôt hamburger ou jambon beurre parce
que aujourd'hui le hamburger il a
complètement dépassé le jambon beurre
mais j'ai envie de vous dire les deux
hein ah les deux j'ai du mal à à être
très engagé sur mes choix j'adore les
deux j'adore un bon burger c'est être
merveilleux quoi vraiment un bon jambon
à la française bien
sûrambon un bon beurre un bon compé rien
de meilleur meilleur ça h mais on
s'entend tous sur cette espèce de de
cuisine un peu street food américaine
est-ce est-ce que vous quand vous étiz
étiez aux États-Unis vous avez vu une
gastronomie américaine ça existe pas ça
si alors moi j'avais il y a un
restaurant que j'adorais du côté de de
Brooklyn qui s'appelait Henry Zend
c'était broken KS c'était un restaurant
de cuisine cajin donc il y avait toute
cette cuisine de louisian qui était bah
voilà très très particulière des des
poulets de la friture mais mais avec une
certaine finesse moi je je crois que
quand on est dans un roit il faut il
faut manger le local il faut être super
ouvert et voilà il y a rien de plus
triste que quelqu'un qui veut rechercher
ce qu'il a laisser 15 jours chez lui
pour aller essayer de voilà non faut
s'adapter faut être super ouvert le
poulet frit c'est un truc qui qui
cartonne aussi et qu'on retrouve aussi
en France aujourd'hui avec des enseignes
qui arrivent
sontat on prend quelques kilos souvent à
la r c'est votre émission qui fait
grossiren parlant j'ai l'ession à la fin
de l'émission vous avez pris quelques
kilos vous allez pasre dçu bon allez on
a tous fini on va passer au dessert oui
et c'est le pêcher mignon
ah alors Brigit avec un fiadon c'est le
gâteau de fête Corse par excellence qui
a pour ancêtre le fiadoni un flan
italien originaire de Coré au départ il
se déguste sur toute l'île pour les
fêtes de Pâques les baptêmes les
mariages les communions alors question
ingrédient on retrouve des produits 100
% cors le fameux bolochu des zestes de
citron ou d'orange de l'eau de vie
locale l'quaviva on peut aussi trouver
du cedra qui est un autre agrume est-ce
que ça c'est vraiment le souvenir de
votre enfance j'imagine non c ah oui à
Saint-Florent ma mère est Corse elle
s'appelle guisog moi mon deuxième prénom
c'est tousin Fran Xavier qui est déjà
marqué très Corse toussin doncent mes
parents voulaient marqu le coup et
d'ailleurs il y a imouvrini
Jean-François Bernardini qui qui fait
une un très beau texte sur sur la Corse
et le vin dans dans le livre et
effectivement le fiadon c'est c'est
toute mon enfance c'est ce sont des
saveurs tellement particulières
je me souviens on rentrait de chez mon
on on all chercher le fiadon chez mon
cousin José salge qui est pâtissier à
Saint-Florent et il est arrivé avec le
fiadon qu'est-ce que c'est que ce goût
c'est très particulier vous allez voir
c'est délicieux c'est un flan mais avec
comme vous dit des agrumes du citron il
y a quelque chose de très particulier et
c'est en fromage en fait le le Broch
qu'on peut qu'on peut sucrer
éventuellement c'est on on le mange salé
ou sucré en exactement exactement c'est
le c'est comme la fetta en Grèce qu'on
pe manger avec du miel et voilà mais ça
c'est c'est c'est le cheesecake voà
c'est ce que j'allais dire vous dites ça
c'est les souvenirs quoi d'anniversaire
de de fête de famille de oui c'est ça
ouais c'est le cheesecake Corse h
délicieux délicieux h il ressemble à
celui de votre enfance mais oui merci on
a fait ce qu'on a pu he c'est un peu
régressif mais on l' retrouvé dans un
restaurant Corse de Paris parce que ça
aussi c'est compliqué de trouver des un
fiadon à Paris c'est pas évident he et
alors vous vous êtes très sucré ou pas
parce que souvent quand on est très salé
ce qui a l'air d'être votre cas on n pas
forcément les deux si vous vous aimez et
tout alors je suis moins sucré que salé
h mais quand la pâtisserie est vraiment
hornme c'est merveilleux mais moi j'aime
bien terminer un repas avec un vin un
peu licoreux
ou un oxydatif comme le bagous le Moris
voilà un cotolulillon ou un Sauterne et
j'aime bien terminer le repas avec ce
sucre là mais mais là le fiadon vous
allez me faire pleurer après les deux
peuvent aller enens je vais vous chanter
le salv
Regina merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivi merci Jean-Pierre et on se donne
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de politique à table sur
LCP